So let's go to our today's
topic. Our today's topic will be uh will
be a bridge between what we have seen so
far. So so far we have been talking
about
uh quite static systems. We always said
like we measure temperature, we measure
we measure pressure. we might repeat
this
experiment. Uh and kind of it was always
always the case that uh that this was
happening in sort of a sort of a steady
state. Basically we were we were trying
to build some static models estimate
some some constant so something like a
steady state of a of some signal of some
of some
process and uh well you have seen it in
your exercises. Yeah, the the latest
exercise the distillation column
basically you were you were given the
data which were almost the uh almost the
steady states if not really the the the
the steady states and uh the subject of
identification would is is more about
the more about the dynamic system. So uh
so far we have we have seen more
statistics applied statistics somebody
might already call it machine learning
or or anything applied applied
statistics but to to let's say static
systems and uh but you are already well
aware for example in your theory of
automatic control now you now you are
studying the discrete time systems is
that right okay Good. So we should today
uh aim aim to make a make a bridge
between the between the static
identification static data analysis and
the dynamic systems and this bridge is
the is uh is called filtration. Yeah. If
we what's the subject of filtration? uh
rumors say that at your course technical
means of automation you have been doing
some some filtration. What was
the what is the the message learned?
What uh stick in your in your mind from
the from the filtration
uh topic?
We can reduce the noise. We can reduce
the the noise. That's that's one of the
possibilities. Uh how
uh there there usually uh came some
adjective like uh this sort of filter or
this sort of filter and one type of that
filter was uh was the one which was
reducing the noise.
I can say that in
Slack filter. Yeah. Low pass filter.
Exactly. Yeah. low pass filter will was
was was the one. Why was it called low
pass or or well the equivalent in
Mhm.
Okay. Good. Low pass. Low pass.
Yeah, good.
Um, why why low pass? What uh what would
the So pass is I let go I let go
something which is low or I make the
Yeah, it's the Lord of the Rings. You
shall not pass. So what will what will
pass is is something which is which is
low. What does it mean this low? What
does it refer to?
H exactly. Exactly. Yeah.
So uh and low
frequency means uh means what in the uh
let's say in the time uh time
[Music]
domain
let's say that I have some well I'm not
sure if I answer the Right question.
Let's try. Let's try. We got the signal.
Mhm. Or can you
use transformation to like change into
summation of the
multiple different signals
and there's like different frequencies
and we just remove those with high
frequencies.
Exactly. Exactly. Yeah. So uh just some
sketch of a signal later I have a I have
even even a even a a better plot. But uh
as as Adam says uh this
signal can
be can be basically basically decomposed
into into two components. The let's say
this will be the high frequency. So the
one which which we see is is changing uh
changing quite
uh quite uh quite a lot almost almost
periodically and the other one which is
basically this uh this this trend that
we that we observe in the in in in the
data. So
our yeah it's of course not not not
bolted to to scale but if we have our
our original black signal then uh the
low pass filter should ideally return us
uh return us uh this signal and uh leave
the the noise which is in the in the
signal signal
apart. So this will be the
ideal low
pass low pass
filter. Of course if this is the output
of the low pass filter then what would
this be? This will be the the output of
the of the highp pass filter.
So, so the highp pass filter should uh
should basically what tell us uh
how in the in the first level of thought
you can say okay uh it can tell us how
how big is the is the noise in our in
our signal or it can also also also tell
us when when the when the signal
signal might might change.
Okay, before going completely into the
into the filter uh filter domain this
these
signals, let's first
uh have some have some little little
word word
about little word about
the filtering in the in the static case.
It does not does not seem does not seem
uh reasonable that we say we are talking
about the filtration of dynamic
signals. Yeah. Get some working area
coup the the one there should be look
looks looks fine. Test it.
So let's say that we have data that we
collected some data from an experiment
in the form of time series. Yeah. uh the
time series, let's say temperature,
pressure, and uh let's say we can we
plot one of the signals that we
got and and we see some something like
this. What's the what's what's the
problem? What what happened here?
Yeah, some there there is some
suspicious suspicious value that we
might uh that we would call out
outlier and uh well what to do with
it? We saw it
remove it to to to remove it. What what
does it
What does it mean to to remove it? One
one possibility is that okay I cut
out that that should have been
red that I cut out like this portion
this portion of the of of the data
subsection of the data for
example last 100 measurements Mhm. Mhm.
Okay.
So,
remove
and and and replace. Um in
the in
the that's that's that's a question
whether whether we should we should do
the uh replacement removal. Yes. But
well if we are if we are interested in
just a steady state model well we might
even we might say okay I have I have
some other data points that
might or other signals that I measure
that might look uh I don't know
perfectly perfectly normal even in the
in the in the in the same window. I can
just say yes. I I just
uh I just uh remove all of these. Well,
because I still want to keep the uh keep
the track on what happened in the first
part in the data. It's well aligned with
the with the between signals one, one
and two. what happens after this uh
after this outlier. So I can uh and the
remove and and replace would then would
then do something like this. It's all
it's already questionable.
away and something like this would mean
either what what Adam you were you were
suggesting that we just copy the the the
past data here or or I would prefer to
use for example from last 100
measurements.
Ah okay. So so so just just in the just
in the past. Yeah. Yeah.
Okay. Okay. Or al also we can
extrapolate somehow.
What does it mean extrapolate?
We can somehow predict
uh predict uh
or interpolate. I mean we we we have all
the all these all these data. So it's
it's not so this this everything is the
past. Yeah. we already collected the
data and now we are one year after after
collection of the of the data and we are
just uh just processing it. Uh so so I
would probably
use the first value in front of it and
behind it and just inter. So last good
value and first good value after the
last good value before the outlier and
the first good value after the outlier
and make some make
[Music]
some make some some sort of a average.
Now if we for example in this situation
would take some uh average of the of the
past values this signal might be good. I
mean well we didn't didn't zoom zoom in
how exactly it it behaves but uh uh here
it might be already already problematic
that we basically uh since we want to
keep the data aligned we got rid of the
possibly possibly good data. So even our
replacement should be somehow in in in
that in that range. Yeah.
Uh so this sort of uh and there are tons
of the things uh you can you can do and
you will be will be doing based on uh
based on what you what you expect from
the from the reality how the system uh
system system behaves.
Um so this all here is uh still sort of
based on the let's say one-dimensional
observation. Yeah. How how how we how we
went about it. We looked at one variable
we spotted some outlier. How can we spot
the outlier let's say auto automatically
like without the without the plotting?
Yeah. because I mean plotting if we have
10,000 signals is not the most uh uh
most fun work to do. So with the how how
can we how can we spot them maybe sudden
change of
gradient or deration
of of of the of of the of the derivative
or we can say that let's say we have
some value and
The next one can be within some zone or
something. Mhm. Mhm. Okay. Yeah. Good
good good suggestions. So,
uh what Yakub says uh we will we will be
be sensitive to the to the change of the
of the signal. We have to be aware that
this signal will have will have some
noise and this this will this will
intervene. Yeah.
uh not saying not saying this is uh this
is uh anything problematic but we should
be aware and this is where uh some
welltuned highpass filter can can help
us
uh
I'll I'll I'll show you an an example in
a in a in a in a second. So in a bell
tuned highp pass filter we would uh we
would get the information about the
noise but uh when the when the signal
changes uh uh changes abruptly changes a
lot its derivative is higher than usual
then then we should also also get this
uh get this
information and
uh so how do we how Do we detect this?
So
detection rate of
change of the of the
signal. That's the that's the Yakub's
approach.
But beware beware the noise.
So we need some some sort of a some sort
of a
filtering and uh what
uh Adam says is uh is what that we find
some uh long-term limits of the of the
signal which is uh which are acceptable
and uh and beyond this these limits we
have unacceptable
uh values. Okay. Uh
can you use the saturation for the
signal somehow?
So even if
what or something we can somehow block
it so it won't reach. Okay. Okay.
Well, so let let's let's first uh let's
first do do the detection because what
you are saying is already how you how
you remedy what you what you do how you
process the process the signal. So but
we can detect uh let's
say uh out
of oh yeah out of
limits whether the whether the signal is
is out of the limits. Uh but okay that's
a that's a very very interesting uh
point.
So let's say we have some some limits on
the on the on the
signal and we can also uh we can easily
then then find out yeah this this this
will be uh this outlier will also be
detected by the by by by this sort of a
limit based uh detector.
Uh how do we get these limits?
For example, that's
a that that that might be the case.
Or we can use the beam.
for the data and say we
can some value. Yeah. What would what
what could that value be?
It depends on that application.
Um, sure. I I'm not asking about the
exact number, but how would you get that
that value?
[Music]
Standard
deviation. Yeah, exactly. So uh yeah we
have we have basically basically two
possibilities or we can combine them but
uh uh either we know physical physical
limits it doesn't make sense that the
temperature in this reactor is at minus
200 Kelvin. Yeah.
Or we or we have
uh or we have some uh statistical
limits.
statistical statistical
limits. The the point is or
the or how how we can how we can
approach approach the the problem. The
definition of of outlier is uh something
which uh which is uh uh rare and uh
which does not conform the the
probability the uh the what our
assumptions about the about the about
the signal.
So we can uh very easily find the mean,
find the find the standard deviation and
then it's uh it's up to
us
to to say okay our limits are then the
mean of the
signal minus and now we can say let's
say three
sigma three sigma of
the of the
mean plus minus 3
sigma. Yeah, that can be that's that's
usually usually applied. What you can of
course of course try to do once
uh let's say you the problem is that if
you are doing this originally the the
outlier is is still in the in the in the
data. So what what happens if you if you
take the outlier into the account? Well,
it will shift shift your shift your
mean, it will shift the standard
deviation. So also a good practice like
a check is once you remove this outlier,
you do the uh the statistics again. You
you find the mean, you find the standard
deviation. If they do not differ that
much then you would say okay the outlier
which I removed was really an outlier
and didn't infer uh with the with my
uh with my statistics
applied.
Yeah. Uh what becomes Yeah. And now we
will have some some pictures but let
me So this was sort of
a very very briefly like
onedimensional analysis. Uh basically we
are looking at one signal at a time. We
are ignoring that that we might have uh
other other signals.
Um the
same same thoughts as we just did can be
applied to the
multi-dimensional multi-dimensional
case. Uh what is the what is a simple
simple
example? So in
the in the ND
[Music]
case we might have
our traditional example let's say some
temperature and pressure along along the
time and
And this these two would be would be
nicely nicely
correlating. Um maybe I just do it even
I just do it even even more extreme.
Let's say ah it's still not enough.
So what if
we let's say there are this there is
this bumps somewhere in our in our data
and if we apply just the one-dimensional
one-dimensional statistics we might say
okay our pressure has been always within
within these these limits.
Um oh so this this this here is is an
outlier. But of course you are sensing a
a problem here. There there must have
been a sit there might have been a
situation that just our operation of
some reactor distillation column and so
on went just
uh out of the out of the
usual usual situation. But anyway uh
when the when the pressure increased the
temperature increased. So this is not a
uh outlier in a form that something went
wrong with our sensor that we recorded a
wrong number in the in in the database.
This is this is just just basically uh
uh saying that there are that that that
some something happened and uh and we
can we can still
uh say that this situation was perfectly
normal because let's just uh let's just
plot this in our correlation plot. Yeah.
So temperature and pressure how would
that how would it look like? We have
some let's say very very usual situation
that would be that would be close to
close to the mean of the temperature
close to the mean of the of the
pressure
and our data here and well that's seems
we have plotted it this way that there
is quite a bunch of bunch of the data
well they are basically just saying
there is there are
some so let's make this cloud
big so let's say this is our mean
situation and there are there are some
some data that are just uh uh with the
higher temperature higher pressure than
usual but they are still kind of uh kind
of showing correlation that we would
even expect from the from the physic the
correlations that are happening in the
in in our in our and
moving
like every 10 values and it's moving and
giving me mean of all
values like like all 10 values but it's
like k + one k + 2 and it's
we will we will use use it in in the in
a second but okay so let's say that we
use uh that we use a moving mean, moving
average. Uh what would what would that
mean? That basically this Oh, sorry.
This should have
been we basically get something
something like like
this. Yeah. Yes. Let's say yeah. And
then the standard
deviation would
be added or subtracted. Okay. Mhm. So,
it's going to be copying.
I Okay, I see. I see what you mean. So,
you uh good idea. This is this is really
used. I didn't want to go that go that
far, but uh yes uh you can you can also
uh so this these uh limits here they are
just basically uh static. Yeah, they are
based on on one number. They are just
the standard standard deviation for from
the beginning of the operation or
beginning of our data until the end of
the window we are we are looking at what
Adam says is uh okay let's have some
sort of a some sort of a window
where what will be uh what what will be
our assumptions our our thoughts behind
uh we don't we don't care much about
what happens Well, not to the not
definitely not in the in the future, but
what even even happened to the past of
the of the signal. So,
wherever however the signal was
changing, you can maybe see it very very
nicely very nicely
here at this
point. Well, however this signal was was
changing this transient effects, they
are they are over. So the data that we
collected in the far past do not
influence our our present present
values and
uh in that way we can actually uh
calculate. So what would happen if uh if
if our window is like this? So basically
our our
mean we will we will identify ba bas b b
b b b b b b b b b b b b b b b b b b b b
b b b b b b b b b b b b b b b b b based
on the based on the black line and maybe
our our standard deviation would look
like the most of the most of the data
points. What would
happen? Let's say if we if we shift it,
how to plot this? There are too many
lines already.
[Music]
Too many too many
deletions. How do I delete exactly this
one? Perfect.
Uh what happens if our if our window
window
was was
shifted somewhere here. So what is the
what is the mean here? The mean value is
somewhere I'm missing the good color to
plot this. Let's try the yellow
one. Yeah. So, here is
the here is the the mean that we would
calculate. Yeah. We just take this these
black values, we calculate mean average,
sum them, divide them by the number of
number of samples, we can calculate the
the standard standard deviation. What
would happen in this case? The mean is
here and we can directly see that the
well the standard deviation here is is
just just small the the the data is is
very is very close to the mean but here
the data is far away from the from the
mean. So even our standard
deviation or plus minus 3 sigma
would would increase hopefully the plot
is still kind of kind of readable and
Adam what to do what to do then
also
probably change
yes that's the that's the dot
line. So now it's like now it's like
this. Okay. So I think it's okay because
we won't
and there's some noise or some I don't
know some spy in it. It will still be
moved to Exactly. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. So
in our previous situation, let's just
look look at these data points because
here it's here it's already already
messy with the with the lines. So in our
previous situation, this data point here
would be out of this overall historical
historical limits and we would consider
it outlier. Here we already uh use
the the
moving moving average
[Music]
Here we already use the the moving
average and uh that basically makes our
previous constant these green limits
uh that that that makes them dynamic.
Yeah, they are small when the signal is
not changing much. They are they are
larger. They grow grow up if the if the
signal is is changing. Good. Very very
nice uh observation. This is this is
what is what is really really used in
the in the practice. We will get to the
mathematics of the of the moving average
uh average soon.
Um also we can use advantage of this uh
of this correlation plot because we
already know about the correlation
correlation
matrices. So uh if
we what was the what was our our case uh
how can I go back? What was our case in
the in the last lecture? We
[Music]
have we have found out
that well we have looked at the multi-
multi-dimensional gausian gausian curve
yeah with the uh coariance matrix. This
is what uh this is when we were doing
the analysis of the of the of the
parameters that we identify from the
from the linear linear regression
and using the correlation matrix the BP
and our sorry coariance matrix coariance
matrix and our estimate of the of the
parameters. we sort of ended up or you
sort of ended up believing me that all
these expressions are uh are equivalent.
So the so the mathematics goes goes like
this. our
our uh uncertain variable be the
parameter here uh its deviation from the
from the mean normalized with the
coarian matrix will be distributed
according to the k square distribution.
If we take the quantile of this
distribution then we can we can arrive
at this mathematical expression which
uh if you want to go go deeper just just
just just let me know but this is
nothing else than the equation of an of
an ellipse. Yeah. And uh as much as we
say we want to uh we want to find
u as much as we say as our confidence uh
will be then the radius of this of this
ellipse will will grow with this
statistical parameter. So we can learn
either the limits of our parameters but
we can also see the correlation.
But come on, we can we can use exactly
the exactly the same thing in this in
this situation. We know how to how to
get the the coariance matrix. How was
it? It was some kind of
a average and we know
this this this matrix matrix not
notation. So we only need
to say if
our x
transpose v
inverse is less or equal
Oh some key square
value. Then this
will this expression here will be will
be if we if we plot it give
us coariance ellipsoid. And what is what
is good about about this this guy here?
Let's say we do it like this.
This will be this this mat here will be
basically our our testing testing
criterion. It is the same thing as if we
before said if some value of our signal
is out of the limits we discard it. We
consider it an outlier. Now we can take
so the x here will be a vector of
temperature and pressure and we can plug
each point that we that we that we have
uh in our database we can plug into this
this expression. If this inequality
holds well that means that this point
will be inside the ellipse will be
inside what our historical data uh data
was was telling. So even if the even the
points like when the temperature
increases when the temperature increases
and the and the pressure increases at
the at the same time will be will be
perfectly valid.
just compare it with the with the
situation if we just take the rigid
limits on both temperature and pressure.
Let's say we have a we have a point like
this in our in our database. If you just
look at the let's say the projection
let's say the values of this uh of of
the temperature and and pressure at this
point if we just say if we just have
our rigid limits. Yeah. So this these
dots
here
well we would consider this point to be
perfectly normal right it's in the range
of the temperatures we have seen in the
historical data it's the pressure is in
the range of the uh values of temp of
pressure that we seen in the historical
data what would it thou uh correspond to
it will correspond to the case we at
lower temperature than usual but we have
a high pressure. Yeah. So it would
correspond
to it will actually correspond to this
sort of a situation.
Uh where is the lowest temperature
somewhere? So let's say this point will
be somewhere here. We have the lowest ah
let's not plot it at the
limits. We have relatively low
temperature, but it might happen that
our that
our pressure
would would still be in its ordinary
limits, but will be will be off of the
of the trend that we would that we would
expect. Maybe even do the plotting of
this guy bit.
bit more down.
Yeah. Yeah. So, this is already
Yeah. Beyond just uh just looking at the
at at at some uh constant narrow limits.
It's really uh trying to guess something
uh some something from the past
historical correlations.
about about the
signal. Sort of
okay. Yeah. Easy to apply and to and to
test. So let's go to the to the real
real dynamic uh real dynamic case. We
have
already we have already discussed quite
a
lot about these sort of a sort of a
plots how to how to arrange
Now I have to remember what was the what
was the original order. Okay. Okay. Now
I I'm I'm getting
there. So this is almost like a fairy
tale. There was a once innocent uh
nicely looking uh signal which was let's
say the real temperature happening
inside of some of some uh
reactor.
Then there was
a there was a bad uh how is it
antagonist villain. There there was a
bad villain coming and uh and this this
guy was called noise and it was
poisoning our uh
our our our measurement. Yeah. So let's
say this is
the original
original
signal. This is
the measurement or or sensor noise.
[Music]
measurement measurement noise and uh and
the sad story is that we don't know
about about any of these because these
two guys will
basically will
basically combine and what we
can ah No. And what what we can what we
can see is just
uh no I find out that they didn't
combine it
well. Okay. Let's let's try like
this. Original signal I would I
shouldn't even even even call it call it
a signal because it's not what we what
we sense. It's the variable that we
would have measured with the ideal with
a perfect perfect
sensor. The ideal sensor doesn't exist.
So we get some measurement noise and
this is actually what what what we
measured. You you can see the noise is
not not that also although the the plot
looks like well there is a lot of lot of
going on. Well, we can we can still even
with our bare eye see that the that the
signal uh is is not not completely
completely
lost. Yeah. So this is
our our
measured our measured response.
Now our our quest will
be now our our quest will be
to use some.
So we already discussed the highpass
filter should should return us some
something like this. Now this
uh this picture we
can we can now
compare.
So this is some real signal I took and I
and I pass it through through some
through some
filters.
Um on the right is the is is the is the
noise is the simulated noise that was
added to the signal. on the left is some
some signal that was that was
reconstructed that uh passed through the
highp pass highp pass filter. What's
what's your observation? What do you
what do you think of this? Is it a good
filtering bad filtering?
bet. If we want
what you want the original information,
what is the original information? the
the what what what we measured is
already a collection of two information
at least because we have the original
signal and we have the noise original of
the original signal. Okay. That's uh
well
Mhm. Mhm. Mhm. Okay.
So, so you you are you are you are
satisfied with the with the
reconstruction of the noise is this they
but they are not the same
right? So uh you are you are correct if
if you if you say it's uh it's it's bad
or if you say well we didn't get the
perfect information about about the
noise and that will of course never
never happened. Uh our uh we our the two
information were were combined and it's
not always easy to distinguish with
them. We can of course tune our our our
filters to be more or less more or less
good. But what this what this guy is at
least
uh at least trying to do I'm not sure
how much how much visible is that it
would still bear maybe maybe this this
point here. Uh oh,
sorry.
Good. It would still try to try to bear.
I know this is bad example. It it also
happens
here. Maybe this one here. Yeah, it's
still still also.
So remember this signal is already got
from the combination of these two. It uh
it still would would hold some
information about the about the changes
of the of the of the original of the
original signal.
Yeah.
Good. Good.
So that would be for our for our
highpass filter. What about the
lowass
filter? So
the low pass filter return returned us
this. Let's compare it again to the to
the original signal. Let's see what what
Adam says that he whether he likes it or
or
not. What do you say if you now now
compare the the the two two
images? That's our original signal. This
is what we got filtered with some lowass
filter. Yeah, it's not the lowass
filter. It's whatever we we say,
whatever we tune
is good. It's good.
Yeah. But it's not excellent. Yeah.
That's that's what you Yeah. So
on the right is already filter. Yeah.
It's better.
Better than not filtering at all. Yes.
Yes. Uh so of course I mean we can see
like yeah the whenever there is a like
spike in the original signal we can see
the spike in the in the reconstructed
signal but it's al also also not uh not
not perfect. Yeah. What is the biggest
biggest thing it what biggest thing it
it misses?
Where would you Where would you say
around number 19? Uhhuh. Uhhuh. Like
Yeah.
It seems to be uh not not even not even
this one but but but also also here the
the signal is is is here the even the
original signal is here changing a
lot and
uh and
our and our our our filter is is saying
okay you cannot you cannot change uh you
cannot pass if you change that fast.
Yeah. So that's that's that's where we
that's where we observe this this sort
of uh this sort of
deviations.
[Music]
Okay.
Good. Oops.
[Music]
So and
now how does the how does the filter
really really work? So let's do let's do
some some mathematics and let's then
transform from the world of some means
averages to the world of uh discrete
time transfer
functions. How does how does the the the
filter filter work? How can we if uh if
we are uh um let's say doing uh
simulation in the simulink we get we get
one of our this comes later we get one
of our noisy
signals. How can
we how can we get our filtered filtered
output?
What was the uh let's let's say let's
say we are Mhm. Saturation
saturation
that that that would not so so for what
for the one
the low pass is it something like RC
filter I don't know electrical
engineering uhhuh but uh okay uh you
have you have all seen all seen the the
the the filters filters in in action.
And maybe maybe you don't even don't
even realize that.
Uh let
me just move this a
bit. So how could this how could this
look like? Let's say we have
some we have some time
axis and
uh let's do just one little change of
our of our raw
signal. Our little
change. Wait, let's see. Blue will be
the raw signal.
There's something more
bluish. So this is our our raw signal in
blue. Uh let's say it will start at zero
and we will we will only do one little
little change of it. It will change to
the value value of one. Yeah, this is
our our signal. Now what should our our
low pass uh filter
do? What should uh what should be the
the red output? Let's say at at this
point or maybe let's say this point like
for for longer
time we the same. Mhm. Okay.
Exactly. Yeah.
So, so what what should happen here? So,
our what is what is coming in changed
changed a lot. Doesn't matter how much
but
changed. What what should the filter do?
Should it jump the same? Yeah. Because
what what if this what if this change
was just was just an impulse? We don't
don't want this kind of uh
simp.
Yeah. But so so so what what what what
does it make it smooth? Yeah. This is
the the simplest example. Uh okay. May
maybe the maybe
the maybe the the the simplest would be
our original signal is doing doing this.
Yeah. So our
oops our output of our
h.
Yeah. So, so here here we here it here
here it shouldn't shouldn't change but
then if we are
here yeah Jakob is is perfectly
perfectly correct with the so
this if this
response looks like well you have all
all seen this right this is like a step
response what would you what would you
say uh how would
the either continuous probably
continuous is is easiest. How would the
the transfer function of this of this
look
like whenever
yeah what's the gain?
Everybody sees that the gain is one.
Right? Because what what should our
filter do? Uh the g the gain is one. If
the signal is zero, the the filter is at
zero. If the signal is one for a long
time, the filter should also converge to
to the to the one. So that's uh that's
uh one of the
um that's one of the key features of the
of the lowass low pass filter in the
long run if the single signal doesn't
changes it should return you the same
signal. Yeah. Okay. And the denominator
[Music]
yes.
Yeah. Exactly. So there is this is even
easier than the uh than any sort of a
dynamic dynamic system because uh well
we have just one uh one parameter one
parameter to fit and that is the time
constant. So if we just change the time
constant we can make this make this
filter arbitrarily slow or or fast. And
this would this would actually say the
how how much we are cutting off how much
frequencies we are letting to pass and
we use
higher order of the system. Yes. Yes.
Uh then if you are if you are using
using higher order of course you can
because basically any dynamic system uh
works as a as a as a filter because any
dynamic system like you simulated in
your control out the theory of automatic
control the two tank system if I change
the inlet to the tank the the height of
the liquid in the tank does not react uh
immediately. Yeah that's the same same
thing as the filter. doesn't get scared
by just one change of the of the input.
It it would need to have to see the
consistent change in the input to react
react that way. Uh and if you are using
the higher order then basically uh then
it's better to to really look at the the
frequency domain because there you can
do magics. Yeah. Uh this is uh what is
uh what is uh used in the audio signal
uh filtering. Yeah. like can you can
really uh damp some some frequencies
like uh yeah there is some some uh noise
of one musician noise of another lower
frequencies are as well really low for
example if
there's somebody for example something
the frequency of the sound is really low
so it's removed as well yeah yeah I'm
not an expert on the on the sound signal
uh filtering. But yeah, these are the
these are the
principles. Good. So this looks like uh
we are just talking about the about the
theory of automatic control. Uh but how
how can
we how can we make this
uh how can
we how can we see some connection to the
to the statistics? Is there some
connection?
uh this is one of my one of my favorite
graphs because it's uh like I do not
need to uh construct some arbitrary
example like what we had what we had
above above uh I'll show you I already
showed you this graph in the very first
lecture lecture we we had I like this uh
uh statistics that got created around
our uh past uh covid
pandemics and this is this is one of
them. So the blue line, blue curve is
the is the original signal. U we have
some time series here. It does not
really really matter what these numbers
exactly are. What is maybe important is
that the uh the granularity is is uh one
per day or in the theory of automatic
control you would say the sampling time
or sampling rate is is one day.
What is the what are the values is the
number of daily PCR cases. PCR was some
method of uh method of testing for the
for the COVID and this is what we got as
a as a blue
curve. What's the problem with the blue
curve? Why is it so so spiky?
Is it uh showing really does it mean
that uh uh in one on one day we got uh
7,000 new cases of COVID but the day
after there was only 2,000 new cases
some accumulation.
Mhm. Because of what? Yes, there is some
accumulation.
What? what accumulated or yeah for
example for it was like it was weekend
so was tested and then on Monday
everybody goes for the test. Exactly.
Yes. So uh if you want to uh check your
uh calendar uh you can you when whenever
you see the the the big spike and now
you can already start to start to see so
the big spike big spike is Monday and
it's not a not a coincidence that
whenever in this picture you see the big
spikes they are evenly evenly
distributed. Yeah, probably Sunday are
then are then these lowest spikes
because nobody was doing the testing or
nobody was reporting. That's even
another another factor there. Okay. And
uh so
uh we were during the pandemics seeing
these blue numbers every day every day
in the in the news. And uh when we were
about to uh uh do do some control so to
uh say whether we are closing down some
businesses, some theaters and so on. We
actually didn't uh didn't uh look at the
blue numbers but we but we get this get
this red curve and this red
curve was in this uh what is it? Traffic
light
coord traffic light. I don't know how to
how to translate it in English but uh
the the filter which is used here is
actually 7
day
moving moving
average that's what already Adam Adam
suggested for our for our
uh filtration to finding whether whe
some some value is uh uh whether some
some value is uh is off its uh off its
limits.
Um so how does it work? Really the
moving average uses some moving or
sliding window. In Slovak we call it
closab primer. Yes.
I give you that. I give you that. Uh the
red number is what I got. So well I I I
I did this in did this in in in MATLAB.
So I I I use the 7-day moving average. I
I can try to to dig this data back and
and to and to see how much it changes
with the median.
Because like
median it's it depends because the
average is actually taking into
consideration are everybody okay every
data we have and the median is just
picking the middle data we have yes
that's a good reasoning about it uh
actually uh uh it it depends on the on
the on the assumption of what is the
what is the statistics what is the
distribution of the of the randomness
what is the distribution of the
uncertainty. So average we have already
proven it uh before in this in this
course. So the average corresponds to
the standard
u standard gausian gausian probability.
uh there is a laplacian probability
there there we don't use the average
there there
the well the so I have heard also
comment for example like where it's
better to use the median mhm let's say
for example if we are talking about the
salaries the average salary like there
may be a lot of people who gain the
minimum
for example. Yeah. Because the
distribution is not like this. Every
salary is going to be like
is going to probably much better than
the median.
Exactly. Exactly. Yeah. So there there
were there were there were some good uh
good reasons why why why they uh choose
the choose the median.
I I I I I don't know. I don't know why,
but
uh average would would work may maybe
maybe maybe almost the almost the the
same way. So how would this work uh
mathematically? How can we say okay we
take a 7
day 7 day window?
with me some you know we yeah we take
some I don't know whether it's seven
days probably it's not seven days yeah
because the seven seven days is between
two spikes so kind of hard to kind of
hard to to select so we need some window
of uh of seven
days so just like in our in our previous
case we are about to see what we can can
we can we do a transfer function of the
7day moving average
uh let's see so our y we can we can
directly directly know it how how could
we could we
calculate let's
say just like you are using in the
theory of automatic control just like we
use until until now. So uh K would uh
would
mean at the current point in time what
is the value of the of the of the red
curve. So the value of the of the red
curve it's what it's seven days average.
So it's taking seven values in the in
the
past including or excluding the the
the current value itself we can we can
decide. So how can
we if the blue signal is again this U
how can we write the write a formula for
the 7day moving average or let's say
some Mday moving average
Y
yk is the output.
Okay. So -
1 to n
um
one is here.
So we need to take uh k k minus one k
minus 2. Okay.
Then from zero to m. So from zero zero
to m wouldn't work. 0 to m is m plus one
values.
No no no no no.
Oh zero to m. If m is
three z one two three it's four
values. And our M
is yeah we are not gonna not going to
take not going to get a get an average
if we are summing n plus one values
dividing it by m.
So how how do we remedy it?
Yeah, basically basically we can we can
decide either we e either we put uh m
minus one here or which or we or we use
use one here. Uh so in this
case yeah we will we will see what what
we'll get. Uh so which uh which values
of you are we are we picking how to how
to write it into this into this formula.
No there is no no
y blue is you. So we are only getting
you and
K
- E I. Yep.
I exactly.
Yeah. So, what did we what did we get
now? What what sort of a what sort of a
filter? Uh we are at the at the time
point K. Yeah, it's uh I don't know
Wednesday 22nd of February
2021 and
uh and uh we are we
just we are summing what? We are summing
from I is equal to zero. So we just K
minus 0 is K. So, we take the number of
cases that that just got out today that
were that were tested today. Uh what is
it? Let's say it's what did I say? It
was Wednesday. So, it's Wednesday,
Tuesday before, Monday before until the
Thursday, Thursday before. Uh we can
also if if just changing these indices
we can also get to the like past uh uh
past evaluation like before we know the
today's numbers which would be like
doing a prediction. Yeah. If the number
of cases in the seven days were like
this then we can then we can
predict. Yeah. So just to say that there
is
a there would be a
little little difference from one to
m.
Yeah, we are not using the the current
value of our of our signal. So this is
already sort of do sort of doing the the
the the prediction the the future future
prediction.
Okay.
So, how can
[Music]
we how can we now turn this
into or how how can we how can we turn
this into into the model of the of the
dynamic system? Let's say in the in the
transfer function form.
Uh so of course
our our
predictions let me take
the the 1 / m inside the inside this sum
uk
minus min - i
And uh let's just compare it with the
with just slight slight
variation. Y k is equal
to i to one until which one I'm taking
one let's take the one until m
uh
variation. Ah, sorry I
missed. Let's just
say
that we do not need to uh really have uh
like this one over m the same for each
each of the of the summons. We can maybe
maybe alternate. Of course, if we if we
say that this
uh that this
B B1 is equal to B2 and that is equal
to
BM
and if the BIS
will will sum to sum to
one. Did we did we do we get the do we
get the same same formulation?
Why?
We don't get
one. Let's test. So let's say that M is
seven. No, that's that's too many too
too many uh additions. Let's say M is
three. So, we just need B1 B2 and B3 to
be equal to each other. And B1 + B2 +
B3 is equal to
one. What's the what's the possible only
possible only possible solution to this?
Mhm.
Right. So, so, so, so we get get one
over m if we repeat it with four, five,
six, seven. So this sort of a
condition for our our bees would uh
would give us the the moving the moving
average
filter. Everybody okay with
that? Okay. So this is the
moving
average
filter. What if we do a slight
variation? Yeah, because now we
introduce sort of a sort of a freedom to
to
our to our filter. We will keep this
[Music]
condition that uh that the sum of these
coefficients will be equal to
one. So sum of bi will be equal to one.
uh we will not uh restrict ourselves
with B's being equal to each
other but uh at least we will say that
the for good reasons the BI is greater
maybe equal to zero for for all
eyes. What kind of what kind of behavior
did we now did we now
allow? Of course um the previous case is
still still inside but this is now much
much more liberal much more free free
condition. What can be an example? Let's
say that
our m is equal to three. So b1 + b2 plus
b3 is are equal to 1. But now we can
choose the b1 b2 b3 more free. Can give
me some some example.
So we can different.
Exactly. Give me some example. What what
could the the b be b1 23 the middle
would be the most
So it will be
0. So one half and the other will be
only half.
Exactly. One quarter. One quarter.
Exactly. Yeah. So this formulation seems
to be quite interesting. We already got
weighted moving
[Music]
average. If we would know that the
testing is weighted moving average
filter. If we would know that the
testing is the most accurate on Thursday
then then then we can make the then we
can make Thursday to decide about the
average uh or have higher influence on
the on the average that we that we
got. Okay.
And
uh so let's now say this is uh this is
all nice.
Uh so this this sort of a model seems to
be seems to be quite quite working. This
y k is equal sum from i = 1 until m b i
u k
-1 and it's got its specific name. It's
uh
called quite
surprisingly
finite
impulse fir response.
And in shorter it's called it's called
FIR fear. You can you can also say FIR
is quite
common.
Um can we do
uh this is the this is the filter that
we were that we were trying to
trying to
find. So if we are about to do its
transfer function, you can do it because
you already know the discrete time
systems and this is a discrete time
system. There is some signal which is
shift backwards in in time. So what do
we need to
get? So
our this is how you how you are denoting
it in theory of automatic
control. And don't worry this this this
one this this one is uh this one is
quite
easy. How can we how can we get there?
Mhm. So the left hand side is what? Z
minus one. And what is our what is the
what is the shift that we that we have?
What is this Z to the power
of? So now our our shift is expressed in
this minus I. Yeah.
What we can imagine here is this is like
minus0.
Yeah. Uh may maybe maybe you are
confused with the with the notation. So
when we say y k maybe you write
something like y t
minus what uh some sampling
time. No this is not correct. Sorry.
Usually it's like y + one. So it's like
it's similar to derivative. So there
will be one z
z to the^ of one. Okay. So this one is
so
not shifted.
We were not
expecting power to zero. Yeah. Yeah.
Because it's one. Yes. Yes.
So may maybe maybe this is this is more
familiar how it looks like on the on the
right hand
side. So we got this B
eyes
and
whoops doing somehow doing it somehow
somehow shorthand.
So what is the what is the shift of uh
of uh of of each u
oops sorry
I don't know
English I
to the power to one Z to the power of
one
uh shouldn't they
be shouldn't they be negative because
they are they are shifted okay good so
it will be Z to the power of one then Z
to the power of two and in terms of the
I
So there will be
some no I mean in each of the sum so I
is equal to I is equal to to one so we
have B1 B1 and U K minus one
u K minus one so we are looking uh not
at the current time k but to the one
time instant before. Yeah. So the
equivalent the shift is then is then
minus one. So z to the power of minus
one. If we increase the iterator in the
sum we have i is equal to 2 then we have
u k minus 2
[Music]
u k minus 2 which corresponds to the z
minus 2. Yeah, you are all all fine with
this with this operator. It is it is
here to here to help us because look
this is very this is very complicated.
Now if I just write c to the power of
minus
one it's saying it's saying the the the
same thing as u k minus this minus this.
So it's just it's just z to the power of
minus
[Music]
one maybe then write me in the in the in
the in the survey where we are of the
the automatic control theory maybe I'm
using using here some some notation okay
so how how will our how will our
transfer function look like
yes exactly
yeah just for the so we have
this tablet is wrong when I'm writing on
the on the
edge yeah
so dy
u y divided by divided by u we need to
divide the the left and right hand side
with the Z to the power of zero. So we
got
this sum in
our sum in our
numerator. And we have
the and we have
the one in the in the in the
denominator. So
we very
easily very easily got into our transfer
function. Now a quiz question from the
theory of automatic control. How do we
find out uh the gain of the of this of
this system if we have it in the
transfer function
form? How is it in the in the time
domain? We can
create usually only substituted s
that that's that's in that's in time
domain. Yes.
Okay.
Z.
[Music]
This is how this uh Z
no there is S times S. Okay.
[Music]
t *
s. So
x Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. So if we are
plugging in the s is equal to zero to
find the steady state. So what would
that mean for the
z one?
Okay. So we can calculate the the gain
of the of the transfer function by just
substituting one for all the
Z's, right? So so what's what's our
gain gain? So plug in Z is equal to one
which is the equivalent of S equal to
zero in the in the time domain.
So what's the gain?
Yes. Easy,
right? No, Marik doesn't doesn't think
so.
Yeah, this this the these are friends.
These are these are are are are very
nice. Yeah, I I get I get gain just by
just by plugging in Z is equal Z is
equal to one. Uh yeah, Z is equal to
one.
So what we were doing doing doing here
before we were just saying that we get a
moving average
uh filter we can now call it well and
our gain is one. What was the gain of a
of a good lowass
filter? Well it it was it was one. If we
now
uh
uh okay no I'm not going into this into
this debate. I wanted to started
something which which needs needs more
time but we will we will do it uh uh do
it next time. So next time we will even
even make uh we will we will break all
the rules. We will even break the rule
of the of the of this sum of B's. It
does not have to be equal to one. And
then we can basically represent whatever
gain of the system. And we will see we
can also represent whatever time
constant of the system with whatever
order of the of the
system. So that's the teaser for the
next time. Any questions to this one?